Iran has rejected an offer for talks
from Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
Tehran cited president Trump's decision
to pull out of the 2015 nuclear deal a
US aircraft carrier was recently
deployed to the region to counter
perceived threat from Iran Charlie
d'Agata was on board and joins us now
from a key waterway and United Arab
Emirates with more on the story charlie
good morning to you good morning well
these waters behind me are one of the
busiest shipping lanes in the world for
oil and gas and keeping them open no
matter what is one of the biggest
reasons that aircraft group is here but
it's also seen as an escalation the
carrier was sent here as a show of force
along with b-52 bombers and hundreds
more US troops we landed on the USS
Abraham Lincoln in the Arabian Sea but
outside this Strait of Hormuz a vital
waterway for the world's oil and gas and
a flashpoint for Iran
this is anything but routine this
aircraft carrier was sent here
specifically in response to Iranian
threats Rear Admiral John FG Way told us
he's personally seen the credible
intelligence suggesting an imminent
attack on US forces what are you
expecting to see or have to manage here
I do not know and it's unexpected and we
just need to pay be prepared for
anything that may come our way if there
is a move to close the Strait of Hormuz
or to threaten or attack us or coalition
forces or interests there will be
consequences
we found the warship on war footing
conducting eighty to a hundred training
and surveillance flights a day what sort
of things are your pilots looking out
for so right now what we're looking out
for is just what is different we're
making sure that we are at a posture
we're not looking to start a war with
Iran we're staying as disciplined as we
possibly can to make sure that there's
no miscalculation now if that carrier
group moves into the streets near Iran
the risk of a miscalculation goes way up
now we asked the Admiral about the
nature of those Iranian threats he
declined to comment
Tony Charlie d'Agata for us in the
Middle East Charlie thank you very much